just this whole whole the carseat stuff  all right ah one step at a time we be  looking anything yes she kind of looks  like you she kind of looks like a raisin  honey can you help me up oh they don't  tell you how painful with this you smell  like you've had some things happen  downstairs let's get to the bottom of  that okay  oh whoa us everywhere that is yeah you  see this mm-hmm  it's a lot bad actually  I can't do this I'm gonna ruin her life  it's just a diaper rash  I can't even change a diaper right  honey I need help get my phone I'm gonna  go get more diapers you're in a row  sorry  you reckon I can figure a boy down it  has been some time and um thinking me  Mike you might wanna know  whoa your biggest blowout yet it's very  impressive  she was finally asleep I really miss her  yeah me too it's been a crazy month yeah  but the best kind of crazy  I mean